it's not going to come as a surprise to
most people in our audience that when it
comes to factual knowledge right now we
have a president that doesn't know much
about economics doesn't know much about
trade doesn't know much about currency
doesn't know much about finances or debt
other than personal debt or credit or
jobs or any of it but that has not
stopped President Trump from having very
strong opinions about all of these
things for sure but in addition to not
knowing about any of these things Donald
Trump has another interesting quality
which is that he's completely out of
touch with the average American so in
other words because he's been rich for a
long time he got rich by building a
business well his family was already
rich he personally built his wealth by
creating a business on the back of a
small loan of a million dollars from his
dad and then even more money from his
dad you have to take that privileged
status and combine it with his ignorance
on so many of these financial issues and
that's where you really get an
understanding that Donald Trump by the
combination of lacking knowledge and
being completely out of touch with the
way that the average person lives he
can't possibly understand your financial
situation and clearly he doesn't
understand your financial situation here
is Donald Trump being asked about
recession recession fears have no fear
Walmart is doing well Trump says and
everyone's rich so how could we possibly
end up with a recession I don't think
we're having a recession we're doing
tremendously well our consumers are rich
I gave a tremendous tax cut and they
loaded up with money they're buying I
saw the Walmart numbers they were
through the roof just two days ago
that's better than any poll that's
better than any economist and most
economists actually say fill that we're
not going to have a recession most of
them saying we're not going to have a
recession but the rest of the world is
not doing well like we're doing the rest
of the world if you look at Germany if
you look at European Union frankly look
at the UK I mean look at a lot of
countries they're not doing well China
is doing poorly parts of Asia are doing
poorly right
Walmart's doing well and people are rich
so
everything's fine and a recession would
be impossible this is what happens when
you combine total ignorance on all
things economic with weaponized
narcissism and the life of blinding
privilege literally blinding privilege
that blinds him from understanding what
the world is like for most people now
what's fascinating is that Donald Trump
isn't merely saying there can be no
recession he's saying if there is one on
the off chance that there is one it will
have been the media's fault as an
attempt to get him to lose the 20/20
election so we can now continue to build
our picture ignorant on all financial
and economic related matters blinded by
ignorance weaponized narcissism and a
level of paranoia that rises to the
level of diagnostic if there were to be
a recession we would blame the media who
has been reporting on me in such a way
to cause the economy to go into a
recession this is the trend under Donald
Trump stocks did well this month Oh
Donald Trump deserves the credit of
course stocks did poorly this month it
was the Fed it was the media it was
China it was whoever the president can
think of but the most disappointing and
outrageous thing is this idea that
everybody is doing well financially
Trump doesn't see and when I when I say
that I don't mean he refuses to
recognize he's just not exposed to the
reality that 40 percent of Americans
can't afford an unexpected $400 expense
without having to go into debt take out
a loan go to a payday loan place borrow
money or whatever the case may be start
charging stuff at interest Trump sees
his cabinet his golf members his family
the people he interacts with every day
and that's it everybody's rich how could
we possibly have a recession when Trump
excuse me when Trump says everyone is
rich I guess he means everyone that
matters to him is rich everyone that he
needs to please is rich so there's the
message from Donald Trump we definitely
would not be having a recession because
everybody's rich but if we did it would
be normal because other countries are
having recessions and it would be the
fault of the Fed and China and the media
definitely not
fault if that were to happen this
counted we've fallen so far in terms of
what counts as political positioning and
discussion in 2019 America that that
position counts as a political position
Trump's been doing great and stocks are
flying high except when they're not it's
because of the Fed and China and the
fake news media whenever I see these
headlines Trump says can't have a
recession cuz everyone's rich I still
have a reaction in my brain deep in my
brain that is a pre Trump reaction which
is there is no way that an American
president would ever say this and that's
by the way after having lived through to
terms of George W Bush I still have that
reaction in my brain Trump used a
sharpie or someone in Trump's
administration use the sharpie to change
the path of Hurricane Dorian on a chart
which we'll get to later that can't be
true oh but it is it is true and then I
look at the quote or I look at the video
or I hear from one of Donald Trump's
flunkies and not only are the headlines
typically accurate the reality of
actually reading the quotes are looking
at the video are often even worse than
the headlines even suggests I hope that
his voters will hold them accountable
now I don't want a recession I know that
there's a contingent on the left very
small that wants a recession in order to
remove Donald Trump that's not me
there's a big contingent of the right
that claims much of the left wants a
recession to remove Trump that's based
on a completely false assessment of the
left I want a good economy if we get one
and Donald Trump is reelected or not
reelected the economy being good is good
for many people even though it still
doesn't work for tens of millions of
Americans if we do get a recession I
still don't want one if Donald Trump's
supporters recognize that it's because
of him at least partially that the
recession was precipitated then the
question becomes will that make them
vote for a Democrat because if not then
it's all merely academic and
hypotheticals so that's what I want to
talk about next how are consumers as
Donald Trump refers to them feeling
about not only the state of the economy
but Donald Trump's role in it now and
his potential role in a future recession